hi I'm Li West for Wired magazine you
know the Canon hb20 was wired to pick
four top camcorder this season it's got
a pretty trim package that's about a
pound and it's about eleven hundred
bucks even though the camera is
technically the same as other HD cameras
and the image is sharper this camera's
main feature is also its main set back
it records the HD v tape high-definition
video so it's the same format that's
used by most TV stations but it's tape
so you're gonna still find himself
rewinding fast forward and we were
looking to leave that all behind looks
like we're gonna have to wait another
year but the cameras other features more
than make up for that shortcoming this
camera has the best Image Stabilizer
we've tested so even if you have shanks
your images come out rocks up
and here's a pretty cool feature for you
aspiring filmmakers this camera records
out a 24 frames per second which is
pretty much just like the bottom line
even though it's pricier than other
ordinary cameras it's a great value for
an HD cam we rated it a 9 out of 10
possible points if it got rid of that
whole primitive tape situation you'll be
close to perfect for Wired magazine of
lee west